ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูเรียมสวัสดีค่ะครูหญิง
ผู้หญิงเค้าสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนไทยแล้ววัน
นี้ที่เราเจอกันเป็นวันอะไรค่ะคุย
วันจันทร์ค่ะวันจันทร์เดี๋ยวเรียงเฉียด
ค่ะ
วันนี้วันจันทร์วันจันทร์วันที่เท่าไหร่
คะ
วันที่ 4
เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนเมษายน
ปีคศอะไรคะ
ปีคศ 2
022 ค่ะ
แล้วปีพศอะไรคะอ่ะอุ้ยดีพ.ต.ต.
2565 ค่ะ
ไม่เข็ดแล้วตอนนี้กี่โมงแล้วคะคืออีก
ตอนนี้บ่าย 3 โมงหนึ่งนาทีค่ะบ่าย 15:00
น
1 นาที
ใส่แล้วรีเรียมเป็นยังไงคะ
เริ่มคิดว่าประมาณ 18:00 นนะเขาแบบรู้สึก
หิวข้าว
ขอคู่เรียมหิวข้าวแล้วยังไม่ได้กินข้าว
เหรอคะ
กินเรียบร้อยแล้วค่ะผู้หญิงแต่ว่าหิว
แล้วครูหญิงล่ะคะ
กินข้าวหรือยัง
ยังเลยค่ะครูเรียงผู้หญิงเนี่ยตรงข้ามกับ
ครูเรียมคู่เรียมในหิวแต่ผู้หญิงเนี่ยฮ่า
ๆๆ
ตัวอย่างกิน
ผู้หญิงกินข้าวเช้าแล้วใช่ไหมคะ
หรือยังกินนิดหน่อยค่ะเพราะว่าแบบวันนี้
เนี่ยไม่ค่อยแบบเวลาเห็นอาหารเอ่อไม่อยาก
กิน
หมู
วันนี้หรอคะเช่าเช้าถ่ายค่ะหน่อยแล้วเข้า
ข้าวเที่ยง
ข้าวเที่ยงยังไม่ได้กินค่ะ
หนูทำไมผู้หญิงไม่กินคะ
เราก็เมื่อวานเนี่ยครูหญิงกินอาหารแล้ว
กินเสร็จแล้วก็โอโห้ปวดท้องปวดท้องแล้วก็
ไปห้องน้ำผู้เช้ายังไม่ได้ลบ
ต่อสู้นะคะ
ลืมลบกระดานจะ
ไปห้องน้ำ
เป็นสมัยห้องน้ำเนี่ย
ผู้หญิงใช่ไหมคะแล้วก็นั่งแล้วก็ห้องน้ำ
ห้องน้ำห้องน้ำเนี่ยหลายหลายครั้งเมื่อ
วานเนี่ยคิดว่ากินอาหารไม่ดี
ก็เลยแบบโอ้ยห้องน้ำเสร็จมันจะออกอีกแล้ว
แล้วก็ห้องน้ำแล้วก็เจ็บอีกแล้วท้องเสีย
ค่ะครูเรียม
ท้องเสียก็คือครูหญิงก็เข้าห้องน้ำเข้า
ห้องน้ำเข้าห้องน้ำบ่อยๆ
แล้วเท่าไหร่ค่ะเข้าห้อง
[เพลง]
ไปหรือเปล่า
ทรายค่ะรู้สึกปวดท้องสมัยเค้าปวดท้องแล้ว
พอปวดท้องแล้วก็เข้าห้องน้ำแล้วก็ออกมา
หนูเข้าห้องน้ำแล้วก็ออกมามันก็รู้สึกแบบ
หมดแรง
ง่วงเวลาเข็นอาหาร
เก่า
ไม่อยากกินแต่ไม่อยากกินพบท้องเสียมาท้อง
เสีย
เหมือนกันน้องทั้ง
ใช่เรียกเห็นบางคนเวลาท้องเสียก็จะอ้วก
ด้วย
แต่พวกไหมค่ะ
ใหม่ค่ะวันนี้เนี่ยเมื่อวานเมื่อวานเมื่อ
วานเนี่ยโอเคไม่ไม่อ้วก
ไม่อ้วกหรอกท้อง 10 ยะอย่างเดียวแต่เมื่อ
ก่อน
เมื่อก่อนเนี่ยอาจผู้หญิงเคยกินอาหาร 1
อย่างที่กินดีแล้วท้องเสียแล้วก็อ้วกแล้ว
ก็ท้องเสียแล้วก็อ้วกแล้วก็ท้องเสีย 2
อย่างพร้อมกัน
ผู้หญิงกินอะไรคะ
กินข้าวซอยค่ะ
ข้าวซอยเข้าซอยเนี่ยเป็นอาหารเชียงใหม่
ใช่ไหมคะอาหารเหนือมีนะคะเข้าซอย
ครูเรียมกินข้าวซอยไหมคะกินค่ะเตรียมกิน
ข้าวซอยโต๊ะกินแล้วก็โอเคนะคะของไม่ได้
เสีย
ใช่ครูหญิงอ่ะชอบเข้าซอยคิดเอาอร่อยมากๆ
เหมือนเข้าซอยหนู
อร่อยแต่มี 1 วันใช่ไหม 1 วันเนี่ยไปกิน
ข้าวซอยแล้วก็ก็เข้าซอยเนี่ยมันจะมีกระทิ
สมัยคะอันเนี้ยกะทิค่ะน้องเป็นน้ำกะทิ
เวลาค่ะเอา
นี่หน่อย
กระทิมหาเป็นกะทิ
ทรายผู้หญิงเนี่ย 1 วันเนี่ยก็จะกินข้าว
ซอยใช่ไหมก็ว่าโอเคเอาเข้าซอยพอเขาซอย
เนี่ยมาเสิร์ฟมาเสิร์ฟเป็นจานแล้วนิ
เราก็กินแต่ว่า
ทำไมเข้าซอยมันเปรี้ยวเปรี้ยวๆ
ผู้หญิงไม่ได้ใส่มะนาวนะทำไมถ้าใส่มะนาว
มันบีบมะนาวเนี่ยมันจะริมันจะเปรี้ยวแต่
ผู้หญิงไม่ได้บีบแล้วก็
ทำไมเข้าซอยมันเปรี้ยว
ทำไมกะทิ
กระทิเนี่ยมันแปลกๆ
แล้วก็ผู้หญิงมีแต่คิดถึงจะหมดไหม
กินหมดค่ะแต่วิ่งก็คิดแบบเข้าซอยร้าน
อาหารกินในห้างไรกินในพาราก็อ่ากินที่
Terminal  Terminal  21 ซอยเป็นร้าน
อาหารที่อยู่ Terminal ก็คิดร้านเนี้ยแพง
น่าจะโอเคเขาซอยก็เลยกินกินหมด
ป่าวกินเสร็จแล้วก็นะระมาณเนอะแล้วก็จะ
ถามว่าวันนั้นที่ครูหญิงไปผู้หญิงไปคน
เดียวหรือว่าไปกับเพื่อน
ไปกับเพื่อนไป 2 คนคนแล้วเพื่อนผู้หญิง
กินข้าวซอยเหมือนกันไหม
ไม่ได้กินข้าวไม่ได้กินเพื่อนกินอะไรจำ
ไม่ได้
แต่เพื่อนโอเคอาหารของเพื่อนโอเคไม่มีก็
คิดอ่าโอเคนะมันแบบมันอร่อยอ่ะเข้าซอยก็
อร่อยดิเออก็กินกินกิน
เสร็จแล้วก็เดินเนาะเดินๆ
ประมาณ 30 นาที
ครึ่งชั่วโมงทำไม 30 นาทีเนี่ยเดิน
ช้อปปิ้งและผู้หญิงใช่ไหมคะค่ะ
เดินไปประมาณ 30 นาทีก็เริ่มแบบกูไม่ถึง
ด้วย
เพราะมันยี่สิบยี่สิบนาทีที่ 30 นาทีแล้ว
ก็สำหรับผู้หญิง
ปวดท้องค่ะหมายที่ที่ท้องไปนานๆๆที่ท้อง
นะท้องตรงนี้เนี่ยรู้สึกหว่ะปวดเวลานั่ง
แล้วนั่งตรงๆแบบไม่ได้ยินทั้งหมดโอ้ยปวด
ท้องแบบต้องเรียนโอเคแต่ถ้ายืดอกป่วนโอ๊ย
ปวดท้องมากๆก็
ไปห้องน้ำ
พอไปห้องน้ำปุ๊บมันก็แบบถ่ายท้องอ่ะก็คือ
แบบขอโทษนะคะนักเรียนนักเรียนคงไม่ได้กิน
ข้าวเนาะ
ก็คือ
ท้อง
ถ่ายท้องหรือท้องเสียอ่าท้องเสียเสร็จ
เปิดอ้วกว่ะ
เราก็ท้องเสียคุยก็คิด
กลับบ้านโอเคไหม
เพราะว่าจากบัสจากเธอมีเน่ากลับบ้านเนี่ย
น่าจะประมาณ 30 นาที
นี้
เข้าห้องน้ำ 1 ครั้งหรือเปล่าคะหรือว่า
เข้าห้องน่าเข้าห้องน้ำในหลายฟัง
เข้าห้องน้ำน่าจะประมาณมีสิ่ง 5 ครั้ง
ใช่คูเรียมแบบ
คุย
ทำไมเพราะว่าเข้าห้องน้ำเสร็จแล้วก็ออกมา
เดินนิดหน่อยมันก็ปวดอีกแล้วคนต้องเข้า
ห้องน้ำแล้วก็แบบอัดอ้วกสมัยแบบดุๆอ้วก
ด้วยก็คือเข้าซอยนะเข้าซอยเนี่ยที่กิน
เข้าไปนะคะเข้าซอยเนี่ยก็รู้รถเข้าซอย
กูออกมาเป็นเข้าซอยขึ้นข้อ
แล้วก็วันนั้นจะมาจนถึงตอนนี้เฮ้ยพี่ก็
รู้สึกเหนื่อยใช่ไหม
เหนื่อยไปหาคู่เรียงผู้หญิงเนี่ยน่าใช่
ไหมหน้าเนี่ยสีเครื่องสีขาวสีเหลืองมือ
ขาวมี
คะใช่ค่ะ
อันเนี่ยใช่ไหมปัดบลัชออนลิปสติกเนี่ยไม่
มีสีแดงสีแดงไม่มีสีแดงนะสีแดงเนี่ยไม่มี
มือก็เป็นสีขาวมันเหมือนแบบอาหารไม่โอเค
แล้วเราแบบ ooooo ท้องมากๆ
หรือว่าถ้าค่าครูหญิงเข้าห้องน้ำครั้งที่
1 ออกมาประมาณกี่นาที 5 นาทีถึง 5 นาที
หรือเปล่าก็ถึงผู้หญิงเดินออกมาจากห้อง
น้ำแล้วก็คิด
โอเค
ห้องน้ำเสร็จแล้วก็แบบปวดอีกแล้วก็ต้อง
เดินเข้าไปใหม่กู
ๆกูมันดับค่ากลับบ้านอีก 30 นาที
นี้จะทำ
ได้ไหวโอเคก็เลยเข้าห้องน้ำแล้วก็ออกแล้ว
ก็ห้องน้ำแล้วก็ออกส่วนรู้สึกแบบแม่เดิน 5
นาทีเดิน 10 นาทีโอเค
แบบไม่เข้าห้องน้ำแล้วก็เลยกลับบ้าน
เกือบท้องเสียมากๆเพราะตอนนี้ใช่ไหมคะถ้า
ครูเรียมกินข้าวซอยวิรัช
ไม่ได้เหม็นเหม็นคิดถึงห้องน้ำวันนั้นที่
เธอมีนอก
ก็เลยว่าไม่เนี่ยค่ะผู้หญิงเนี่ยเคยกิน
ข้าวซอยแล้วก็ท้องเสียนะแต่ประมาณ 5  5  6
ครั้งพอกลับถึงบ้านถึงบ้านเนี่ยก็เข้า
ห้องน้ำอีก 1  2 ครั้งเกาะโอเครอใช่ไหมคะ
เพราะพรุ่งนี้ไม่ท้องเสียแล้วก็โอเคแล้ว
ไม่ได้ไปกินยา
จะใช้
เป็นซื้อยาแบบ
ที่เซเว่นอีเลฟเว่นอ่ะดิเซเว่นอีเลฟเว่น
มันจะมีเหมือนเป็นแคปซูลตอนนั้นอาหารเป็น
ยาสมัยเป็นยาแล้วก็กินอ่ะเราก็จะมียาที่
เป็นน้ำน้ำ
เป็นขวดและสำหรับเวลาปวดท้องก็กินจิบจิบๆ
นิดหน่อยนิดหน่อยก็โอเคก็เลยไม่ได้ไปโรง
พยาบาล
โรงพยาบาลปิดปอบอีบอกไม่ได้ไปโรงพยาบาล
ไม่ได้ไปก็โอเค
ใช่เราไม่ใช่แค่เข้าซอยนะคะ
กำลังจะถามว่า
ผู้หญิงเคยกินอะไรแล้วท้องเสียอีกไหมคะ
หรือว่ากินข้าวซอยแล้วข้องเสียแค่ครั้ง
เดียว
มาย 3 ผู้หญิงมากินข้าวซอยแล้วก็ท้องเสีย
แล้วก็เคยกินอันนี้ค่ะครูเรียม
นี่ค่ะ
อันนี้เราเรียกว่าอันนี้เป็นปลาหมึกนะ
ครับปลาหมึกหน้าอันนี้เมนูนี้เนี่ยล่าปลา
หมึกนะคะนะเนี่ยเคยกินลาบหมูลาบไก่เนาะ
แต่อันนี้เนี่ยล่าปลาหมึกนะครูหญิงเนี่ย
ตั้งเคยท้องเสียครั้งแรกนะครั้งแรกเลย
ครั้งแรกที่กินอาหารแล้วท้องเสียก็คือกิน
ล่าปลาหมึก
โอ๊ยปวดท้องแล้วก็ไปห้องน้ำห้องน้ำน่าจะ
ประมาณ 3-4 ครั้ง
น้องผู้หญิงได้แต่พวกไหมค่ะอ้วกไม่อ้วก
ค่ะไม่อ้วกไม่อวบอาล่าปลาหมึกเนี่ยท้อง
เสียท้องเสียอย่างเดียวไม่อ้วกแต่ถ้าเป็น
เข้าซอยพูห์โห
เขาซอยเนี่ย
อิอิอิอิ
2 อย่างนะซ้ายแล้วก็มีอีกหนึ่งอันที่อัน
นี้หลายๆคนเนี่ยกินแล้วน่าจะท้องเสีย
เหมือนกันเพราะว่าคนไทยกินกินแบบซาชิมินะ
คะไม่สุก
อะไรคะ
หอยนางรมค่ะนี่แบบนี้เลยนะกินแบบนี้เลย
ดิบใช่ไหมมีหอยนางรมก็
คูเรียมกินไหมคะหอยนางรมขึ้นค่ะเตรียมกิน
ดิบๆเหมือนกัน
กินแต่ว่ามึงแล้วครูหรือขอกำไรก็หาหรือ
ว่าครูเรียมกินหอยนางรมแล้วท้องเสียไหม
ไม่ไม่ท้องเสียค่ะแต่ว่าเร็วกินแค่ถ้าทำ 2
ครั้งเขาว่าไม่ได้ชอบหอยดำรงก็กินเดียว
แล้วก็ไม่ทองเมื่อก่อน
สายผู้หญิงชอบทอมหอยนางรมมากๆแล้วมี 1
ครั้งกินแต่แบบหนึ่งจริงประมาณ 1 ตัวสอง
ตัวนะก็คือกินเนี่ยอ่ะหนึ่งสองพอแล้วไม่
กินมากๆ
แต่ว่าท้องเสียอะไรหายปวดท้อง
ตัวท้องปูปวดมากๆกดแบบเดินไม่ได้อ้ะน้อ
กินแค่สอง
ฝ่ายก็เลยแบบไม่กินหอยนางรมเหมือนกันตรง
มาเวลาเห็นหอยนางรมแล้ว
น่ากินนะคิดหูอร่อยใช่ไหมเราก็คิดท้อง
เสียไม่เอาดีกว่าเอารถตอนนั้นที่ควีนกิน
หอยนางรมเข้าห้องน้ำไปกี่รอบค่ะ
ก็ห้องน้ำน่าจะประมาณ 3 รอบ 4 รอบคือ
ไม่ไม่ไม่ได้เยอะมากแต่ว่ามันปวดท้องราคา
มันปวดท้องแบบผู้หญิงเจอน่ะเดินเดินเดิน
เดินไปเข้าห้องน้ำที่อพาร์ตเมนต์นะที่
บ้านอ่ะนี้ที่บ้านแล้วก็เดินออกมาแล้วก็
เดินไปเข้าห้องน้ำแล้วแบบ
ไม่มีแรงอ่ะครูเรียมคือมันไม่ใช่มีแรง
เพราะว่าท้องเสียนะคะค่ะแต่ไปห้องน้ำแล้ว
มันปวดท้องมากๆแบบอ๋อไม่ไหวพี่ก็เข้าห้อง
น้ำมาแล้วก็เนี่ย
นั่งอยู่หน้าห้องอันนี้อันนี้ห้องน้ำใช่
ไหมคะ
โซนนี้เป็นห้องน้ำของเราเนาะแล้วจะมี
ประตูเงินประตูผู้หญิงมาแล้วก็ได้ที่นี่
เลยค่ะแน่
นอนหน้าห้องน้ำพระบาทมันปวดท้องมากๆอ้ะ
ขั้นปวดท้องหรอก
น่าจะจำได้เพราะว่าเป็นครั้งสุดท้ายที่
ท้องเสียน่าจะตอน
2018 เท่านั้นอ่ะ 2018 กินหอยนางรมแล้ว
ก็ปวดท้อง
ประมาณ 4 ปีที่แล้ว
ถ่ายค่ะสีปีผู้หญิงก็ไม่กินหอยนางรมกับ
กลัวมากๆเพราะมันมันปวดท้องมากๆค่ะแบบ
เนี่ยผู้หญิงต้องเดินไม่ได้ก็นอนหน้าห้อง
น้ำอ่ะแล้วก็พอกับพี่ก่อนไปห้องน้ำก็ออก
ป่า
มายค่ะมายไม่ท้องเสียอย่างเดียวท้องเสีย
ท้องเสียอย่างเดียวแล้วแต่ครูเรียมเนี่ย
กินหอยนางรมไม่ได้ข้อเสียชายไม่ได้ท้อง
เสียอายแป๊ะแล้วคู่เรียมเคยท้องเสียไหมคะ
เรื่องจำได้ว่าเคยท้องเสีย 1 ครั้ง
ก็คือกินกินกินอะไร
ลืมเอารูปให้ดูและเรียนยอมอีกไม่โอเคนะ
แต่ผู้หญิงชอบนะชอบเราหมึกมากๆ
เอาผู้เตรียมกินปลาหมึกอะไรอ๋อปลาหมึก
ย่างปลาหมึกย่างค่ะเราก็ทำงานที่เท่า Good
เอาปลาหมึกมาจิ้มแล้วก็กิน
อร่อยมาก
แล้วคุณเรียมท้องเสียเนี่ยปวดท้องไหมคะ
ปวดท้องค่ะเหมือนกับผู้หญิงปวดท้องแล้วก็
เข้าห้องน้ำเข้าห้องน้ำเข้าห้องน้ำเข้า
ห้องน้ำบ่อยๆอ่ะ
อีกครั้งอ่ะครูเรียนจำได้ไหมครับ
ประมาณ 4  5  3
9 พวกไหมคะ
ไม่ค่ะไม่อ้วก
ดีค่ะ
ของเสียด้วยครั้งเดียวที่ท้องเสีย
กิน
จริงคือคุยอิ๋งนะคะปกติกินอะไรก็โอเคนะ
ไม่ท้องเสียอันนี้ไม่เข้าใจ
ไม่รู้เหมือนกันค่ะแล้วก็ตอนนี้ก็ยังกิน
นะก็ยังกินปลาหมึกปลาหมึกย่างใส่ผู้หญิง
ผู้หญิงก็กิน
วิ่งจ๊อกกิ้งนะคิดอะไรนะกินค่ะกิน
ลาบปลาหมึกใช่ไหมคะล่าปลาหมึกคือผู้หญิง
คิดว่าอันนี้เนาะอ่ะล่าปลาก็คิดว่าน่าจะ
ปลาหมึกมันไม่โอเคเหนื่อยมันนานแล้วแบบ
มันเราจะเหม็นเหม็นๆใช่ไหมพอเรากินเข้าไป
ก็เลยท้องเสีย
อะไรแต่ถ้าเป็นอ่าเข้าซอยอันเนี้ยเข้าซอย
เนี่ยเราอ้วกด้วยก็เลยว่าพี่ไม่กิจกินกี่
ใช่มั้ยเดี๋ยวก็เลยคิดว่าสายเกิดแบบกิน
อะไรแบบกินคำแรกเราคิดว่าไม่โอเคลืมก็จะ
ไม่กีด
ที่พี่ก็คิดเหมือนกันนะพี่กินข้าวซอยแล้ว
ก็รู้สึกว่า
แต่ก็กิน
ไม่ไม่กินแล้วนะคะเพราะว่าแบบโอน่ากลัว
มากเข้าซอยกับตัวท้องอายอ้วกอาเจียนอ่ะนะ
อ้วกแล้วก็ท้องเสีย
เราก็ไม่รู้ว่านักเรียน
สายนักเรียนไม่ได้กินอะไรแล้วท้องเสียไหม
ใช่ก็คอมเม้นท์บอกเราได้นะคะนักเรียนจะ
บอกว่ากินส้มตำท้องเสียผู้หญิงได้เป็นคน
กินส้มตำไม่เคยท้องเสียเลย
ใช่ค่ะเดี๋ยวก็เหมือนกันกินส้มตำบ่อยมากๆ
แต่ก็ไม่เคยท้องเสีย
สายส้มตำปูไงมีปู
ก็ไม่ท้องเสีย
แต่ล่าปลาหมึกท้องเสีย
ไม่เข้าใจเหมือนกัน
นะ
วีดีโอนี้ลากหมดเวลาหมดแล้วค่ะค่าเวลาหมด
แล้วน้องเดี๋ยวเราเจอกันใหม่วิดีโอหน้านะ
คะคะสำหรับวันนี้สวัสดีค่ะสวัสดีค่ะ
บ๊ายบายน